[Música]
i
eu sempre quis mudar o mundo
aqui todos for sap quente vocês não
perceberam a eu nasci montenegro uma
cidade do interior do rio grande do sul
uma cidade que queira em uma família que
lutou muito para virar os privilégios
que eu tenho hoje e essa vontade que eu
tinha de mudar o mundo ela foi mudando
ao longo do tempo e talvez lá no início
ficava um pouco mais fechado em mim
agora vocês vão apresentar minha família
sou filho do zé empresário tem uma ótima
na cidade
daliane professora aposentada do estado
sou mais velho augusto meu irmãozinho
ele está com uma carinha fazer olhando e
aliado a essa mudança a vontade de mudar
o mundo que eu tinha que estava um pouco
segura dentro de mim fechada dentro de
mim que não botava pra fora eu queria
ser do meu negócio
vencedor no negócio implica como você
pode ver na imagem definir a hora que eu
ia ter fome e de sede e não tem alguém
definir na hora que tomar alguma coisa
podem ver pela cara do meu irmão ali ele
está olhando com cara de por que está
fazendo isso e aí eu pensei beleza
lógica simples eu vou estudar o negócio
e quando me aposentar eu tiver 60 e
poucos e oitenta e poucos anos sei lá eu
ia poder ter tempo e dinheiro pra poder
de fato mudar o mundo
só que aí o tempo foi passando fui
percebendo cara isso é muito chato vai
ser muito chato
primeiro eu nem sei se vou chegar lá vou
parar de trabalhar
eu vou ter dinheiro para poder mudar a
vida de alguém
isso foi meio que se mexendo dentro de
mim e eu entrei na faculdade com essa
latinha 1 17 anos bicho de administração
apavorada sem saber o que fazer da vida
sem saber o que fazer da vida
aí passou um tempo me formei continuava
sem saber
beleza não chegou a fazer o trabalho do
meu pai erótica
enquanto isso eu buscava aquilo que era
definido como médico de sucesso na época
precisava passar um processo de trainee
não passa a ser um fracassado
era isso que eu estava na minha cabeça
só que sei lá eu não passei no teste de
loja
temos 20 processo de trainee e a lei
essa frustração
o que me deixava mais frustrado é que eu
percebia que o tempo estava passando e
não está fazendo nada de fato pelas
pessoas
foi aí que conheci um cara não é uma
foto é o thiago matos
ele é um fofo turista brasileiro que
abriu os meus olhos de muita gente pra
várias coisas
a primeira delas é que a gente enxerga o
mundo eu entendi que a gente enxerga o
mundo através das lentes daquilo que a
gente viveu dos nossos privilégios nosso
mais sete da nossa cultura mas a gente
tem um grande componente que nos fornece
as notícias para a gente acompanhar
diariamente a mídia e se a gente for só
pelo que a mídia diz
a nossa vida vai ser um brasil urgente
uma linha direta a gente vai pensar que
a qualquer momento que a gente sair pode
acontecer alguma coisa pra gente ou para
a nossa família
a gente está correndo perigo e faz
sentido que a mídia transmita isso
porque o nosso cérebro é uma coisa
chamada amígdala responsável prestar
atenção em tudo aquilo que afeta nossa
existência
ou seja notícia ruim vende e aí através
dele conheci também o peter diamandis um
outro grande futurista a nível mundial e
que ele apresentava alguns dados que iam
contra me fazia pensar diferente daquilo
que a mídia me mostrava por exemplo a
expectativa de vida no mundo aumenta
cada vez mais a morte por desastres
naturais cada vez menor porque a gente
está cada vez mais preparado o acesso à
eletricidade cada vez maior inclusive
nos países mais pobres
o custo da energia solar ea energia
sustentável cada vez mais barata ea taxa
de subnutrição de novo possível os
países mais pobres a cada vez mais baixo
e muito disso se dá o fato daquilo que
se chama de lei de morar lá dos anos 60
a gente conheceu isso através do recurso
é que a tecnologia evolui
esponencialmente e aí ele dizia lá nos
anos 60 que a cada 18 meses dobraria a
capacidade dos processadores
tecnológicos e com isso o preço cairia
pela metade
hoje essa lei já é praticamente varrida
por cada vez mais rápido ea gente pensa
assim faz com que a gente consiga
através de outra lógica e oswaldo
oliveira apresentou pra gente que é a
lógica da abundância que é eu vou
explicar para vocês como é que a nossa
sociedade vive hoje e ele conta pra
gente como é que é como deveria ser a
gente opera sob a lógica da escassez
a gente pensa que determinados recursos
não vão ter para todo mundo
com isso a gente vai ter medo que lhes
falte a competir para estocar a gente
vai retirar de circulação com isso o
custo vai aumentar por causa da lei da
oferta e demanda ea gente de fato a
excluir que não têm para pagar
e aí aquilo realmente aquele recurso
realmente é escasso e faz sentido que a
gente vivesse sobre a lógica da escassez
porque até hoje alguma parte do mundo
ainda assim o quadro poderia ver o
império houve um bombardeio poderia vir
uma peste poderia acabar com tudo aquilo
que a gente conhecia como sociedade
aquela comunidade que a gente vivia
então está embalado na gente mas vou
mostrar pra vocês esses dados pode que a
gente possa inverter a lógica como
propõe o osvaldo é pensar que
determinados recursos vão ter para todo
mundo
com isso a gente vai acreditar que vai
ter a gente vai colaborar para criar em
torno daquele recurso art vai aumentar o
fluxo de ide no mercado lei da oferta e
da oferta e demanda o custo ele vai
diminuir ea gente vai incluir quem não
tem pra pagar
e aí de fato que lula vai ser abundante
quando a gente meio que entendeu isso
tomei um soco na cara em todos os
lugares do corpo porque ali eu
identifiquei uma oportunidade que eu
podia mudar o mundo com um negócio
e aí eu me juntei essas duas pessoas
maravilhosas que o meu irmão augusto meu
primo do que a gente criou uma empresa
em 2016 que opera sobre a lógica de
autogestão uma política de salários
iguais a todos
o objetivo da direção ao mundo um lugar
mais aberto referente do bem vendendo
produtos em quase papel sempre se chama
dobra e eu resolvi separar hoje três
coisinhas que a gente faz que eu
acredito que são bem legais para todos
você saber
a primeira delas é que a gente trabalha
com parcerias com a colaboração então
todas as estampas são criadas por
artistas qualquer pessoa pode desenhar
uma estampa enviar para a gente
e aí algumas pessoas com a menina
comprou o vestido de casamento dela com
a renda que veio das artes um dos
momentos mais importantes da vida do ser
humano
a marcha 11 mandou essa foto semana
passada ela conseguiu pagar um quarto do
intercâmbio dela de seis meses por
canadá com a renda das estampas e eu
jamilson que mandou e mail superfeliz
porque a gente além de inspirar ele a
querer mudar o mundo e fazer diferente
a gente conseguiu arrecadar 100 por
cento do capital para realizar o sonho
dele abrir uma empresa junto com o pai
dentro de casa
outro detalhe importante é que o nosso
segredo industrial tá aberto no nosso
site para qualquer pessoa baixar é o
nosso molde e um vídeo ensinando a
montar o produto que a gente vende de
graça
com isso a gente faz com que pessoas que
não têm recursos para comprar um produto
nosso possam produzir um produto nosso
com seu próprio recurso sem nos pagarem
um valor esse que o fato fez com que
alguns projetos sociais com o projeto
identidade fosse sustentado esse projeto
acontece lá em recife
no outro extremo extremo do brasil e ele
é alfabetizar jovens adultos e idosos
analfabetos hoje 50% da renda do projeto
vem da venda das carteiras que a gente
disponibiliza um molde não recebe um
centavo por isso
outro detalhe é mais um a gente separa
um real de cada produto vendido em
parceria com uma empresa que dê de porto
alegre para realizar realizar projetos
sociais
o primeiro deles chama bons a dobra a
gente foi uma escola estadual no na
nossa cidade
a gente falou para as crianças que elas
têm a oportunidade de mudar aquilo que
elas tinham vontade na escola e ela
definir o que seria o empate
a gente falou pra elas beleza agora a
chance está na mão de vocês desenha as
carteiras mais lindas do mundo
a gente vai colocar à venda no site e
todo o lucro vai ser destinado para a
gente reformar esse patife juntos
projeto no ar está sendo super legal
aí a gente pensava nossa que maravilhoso
nós temos a melhor empresa do mundo a
empresa mais legal demais faz bem pra
comunidade ea gente foi atrás disso
queria saber um pouco mais e aí a gente
descobriu que existe um certificado que
certifica empresas que são legais
expliquei que não estava sozinho e que a
gente uma empresa pequenininha no
interior do rio grande do sul poderia
estar junto de empresas
gigantes multinacionais empresas aqui no
rio grande do sul
esses certificados instituição se chama
sistema b
eles dizem que eles estão redefinindo o
conceito de sucesso nos negócios e eu
acredito muito nisso porque isso nos fez
repensar
será que o sucesso está só no lucro só
no quanto a gente arrecada e eu gosto
muito desse resumo que eles mesmos se
colocam como sistema b quem uma empresa
que é certificada bem não é a melhor
empresa do mundo é melhor para o mundo e
essa palavrinha faz toda a diferença
e foi aí que eu percebi que eu beleza lá
fantasiado disfarçado de clark kent
tinha essa vontade de mudar o mundo e eu
e meu irmão e meu primo do eu augusto a
gente também
a gente juntou as nossas vontades para
criar algo maior
hoje nós já somos 20 pessoas dois anos e
meio que eu agradeço muito travesso
demais as pessoas porque dedica a sua
vida a algo maior a mudar uma realidade
no país está precisando
essas 20 pessoas se abriram para atender
a comunidade agentes abril com a
plataforma à comunidade pelo gol na
gente para poder gerar renda para poder
gerar mudança gerará inspiração hoje a
gente já não consegue mensurar quantas
pessoas
a gente consegue impactar o nosso
trabalho e aí eu entendi pouco tempo de
vida que não existe o futuro a gente
fala o futuro que a gente fala aquilo
que a gente vai construir
então se a gente quer um mundo melhor
diz a fazer melhor se a gente constrói o
que é o futuro ea gente quer algo melhor
esta construir agora hoje algo melhor e
aí eu percebi que essas coisinhas que eu
falei pra vocês não são coisinhas
pelo contrário elas são pequenas
inspirações que vão gerar as grandes
revoluções na sociedade e de fato mudar
o mundo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]